لا شيء محسوم في السودان سوى ان المواجهات
مستمره وتتصاعد وتييرتها وسط غياب حسم
ميداني في مواقع الاشتباكات الاستراتيجيه
حتى الساعه
المواجهات في العاصمه لا تزال على اشدها
وتتركز حول نقاط توصف بالسياديه البدايه
من القصر الجمهوري اذ اكد مصدر عسكري
للجزيره ان افرادا من الدعم السريع يوجدون
داخل القصر محاصرين بالكامل واضاف المصدر
ان وحدات من الجيش تصدت لهجوم الدعم
السريع على مقر القياده العامه للجيش
وتوقع المصدر العسكري ان يستخدم الجيش
تعزيزات الى العاصمه قال المصدر انها
ستكون كفيله بحسم القتال مع جيوب
الميليشيات في وقت وجيز حسب تعبيره
وتستمر المواجهات في مناطق كوبر والسكه
الحديديه وحي البابورات بالخرطوم بحري
واكد مراسل الجزيره ان الاشتباكات لم تخفض
في منطقه شرق النيل شرقي الخرطوم مع تضارب
الروايات بين الجانبين
الى مراوي حيث الوضع مشتعل منذ اليوم
الاول
استعادت قوات الدعم السريع السيطره على
المطار في اليوم الثالث من القتال بعد
استقدام تعزيزات للمنطقه ما ادى لفقدان
الجيش سيطرته على المكان
ونقل مراسل الجزيره ان الجيش السوداني
يستخدم الطائرات في المعركه الدائره وتحدث
مراسلنا عن وقوع اصابات في عمليات الكر
والفر بين الجانبين وفي نيال بولايه جنوب
دارفور غربيه البلاد افد مراسل الجزيره
بان معارك عنيفه شهدتها المدينه بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع حول مقر قياده الجيش
وان اسواق نيالا شهدت اعمال نهب وحرق
واسعه
اما ولايه البحر الاحمر فيقول الجيش انه
السيطره على جميع مقر قوات الدعم فيها بعد
ان كان قد بسط سيطرته امس على مدينه
بورتسودان